from the Minnesota Vikings Adam feeling
back here in the riches and she'll how
are you sir I'm doing great how about
yourself I am doing well how's that leg
of yours doing it's doing good it was a
nice get back out there with my
teammates and playing ball again so
excited too you know a nice obviously to
get that game one of my belt you know
knock some of the rust off and get back
to playing ball okay I don't know if
you're aware you weren't just playing
for the Minnesota Vikings you were
playing for a team called badonkadonk
zero zero which is the team that my kids
and I draft and fantasy and and your you
are the star wide receiver of that team
Adam were you realizing that weight
around your shoulders all season long oh
that's probably not good you probably
don't like me very much right now a lot
of a little bit of heat from my fantasy
owner you know what Adam your fantasy
owners are a guy like me where I'm even
keel 11 eight and six-year-olds so and
again I know if you heard that part of
the name is badonkadonk so it's not that
intense but but I I imagine it has been
you know a word that has been associated
with you quite a bit from beginning to
end frustrated I want to touch a little
bit on though that word with you in this
season are are you frustrated about what
your season has been for you personally
Adam I can honestly say no um yeah there
was definitely moments of frustration
but but for me my focus was to not get
frustrated and to support my teammates
and and you know come to work every day
and try to do whatever I could to get
back on the field and to help out so for
me honestly you mean you can ask my wife
who's around me every single day I
really I really didn't get frustrated
and obviously it helps that your team is
waiting without you so that keeps away
from some frustration but yeah you know
it definitely was an interesting process
and definitely have learned a lot from
that process so there's a lot of
positives I can take from it I'm back
playing against though it's all good it
is all good and then the way that the
season began
you and Diggs made some public comments
that many in the media including me
nationally read into some serious issues
within your offensive house you're the
first one Diggs came and he I guess
tripled down a week later things have
vastly improved that said do you think
things would have vastly improved if you
and Diggs had not said something like
you did earlier on in the season I think
they would have good I know the coaches
be having this and then you know in this
building and the players we have in this
in this room as an offense so you know
it was nothing that they didn't know and
it was very you know like you said a lot
of people are read into it more than it
was you know it was as simple as it was
said you know you can't win football
games by being one-dimensional and every
offense and the NFL will tell you that
so like I said it was probably read and
do more than it then it really meant to
be it was as simple as that is is you
have to be able to throw the ball you
have to be able to Pat to run the ball
to win in this league when you look at
teams that have won Super Bowls or made
it deeper on the playoffs you know they
can do both they aren't just
one-dimensional I mean yeah at the time
you were mentioning how you're not going
to be able to run the ball for 180 yards
even with the best running back in the
NFL it's kind of like you basically
saying hey I'm open were you open you
know you know because you know I go back
and look at that Packer game from early
in the season now that we're playing the
Packers again and um you know there was
times where I could have done my job
better and there's times where you know
you get open and don't get the ball but
that's that's part of football you know
if you look at any you know 60 minutes
of any football game there's going to be
times where receivers getting opened not
getting the ball that's just part of the
deal and a lot of times you know
sometimes you have a part of the
progression and you're getting open so
you're not going to get the ball
regardless so um you know it's just one
of those things as a receiver it's tough
as a competitor yeah you want the ball
and things like that but you got to
understand the big the big picture of
things and the grand the grand scheme of
things no I know it's all at your atoms
dealing here on the rich guys enjoy it
is all a journey I mean a football
season is a journey and there's a lot of
downs a lot of or if you're fortunate
ups as well
all that said before we do get to the
hearing now after you said what you said
Indig said what he said a Kirk Cousins
publicly apologized what did you think
of when you heard that at the time yeah
this is the type of guy he is you know
he he's gonna take ownership even
sometimes when it's not his fault you
know and and he's just a really good
person and a great teammate and a great
leader and you know he's gonna do the
the overly nice things sometimes and no
it was another one of those things that
just gets overblown people read into it
things like that but you know it is what
it is and ever since that he's and he's
been falling out so you know kind of a
bummer that he didn't make the Pro Bowl
because he's been playing about that
type of level since then so obviously
it's great to see a guy who Buster's
tale day in and day out and cut it so
much about his teammates and winning did
he say anything to you off camera behind
the scenes about all those no we we
talked we talked up every game right we
talked about our frustrations we talked
about what would bad so you know it's no
different than what what we talked about
after the Chargers game you know and
that's that's something that I think
that really good teams do is they
criticize their play they criticized the
game play whether it's a blowout win or
a blowout loss they're gonna criticize
it the same so that's something that
we've we've had a lot of great dialogue
you know over the last couple years I'm
just talking through games and sometimes
it's just you know getting off your
chest how you feel about the game and
you know sometimes that's their music I
guess yeah I bet I bet when you refer to
charge your game you mean your your most
recent home game in Southern California
right on you sort your friends right
that's right you know I thought I'd get
the have a home game and some warm
weather we don't get a lot of them it's
amazing how many how many Norseman and
women showed up this past weekend huh
yeah we you know we knew going into the
game that there was gonna be a lot of
fans but it over exceed our expectations
you know that was 75 percent for me you
look on if you just looked at behind our
offense I mean I don't think there was
one charger and behind us so it was
really cool
what a great
there's definitely a different feel in
that environment you know smaller
Stadium and not having got that many
home fans it was definitely a weird
atmosphere but but really cool well it
was the second time Adam Thielen here on
the Rich Eisen show that game for you it
was the the second time in three weeks
in which Dalvin cook had to leave with a
shoulder injury
what can you inform us best you can
about his status or his his shoulder and
and the way can maybe hold up and a game
I'm sure the Green Bay is gonna be
gunning for it yeah that's a great
question I've been trying to figure that
out myself obviously I would love to
have him on the field and the type of
player he is and the seasons he's having
you know he's a big piece too often it's
probably a feet biggest piece you are
off and so you know we're hoping he can
get back out there and play and we know
he's a tough kid he's gonna do whatever
it takes to get out there and and we're
hoping like I said that he's out there
and helping his team when and how has
his production changing on offense Adam
you know I think I think it's so many
different ways you know it makes
defenses play us differently
it makes them have to respect both the
past game in the end the run game and
you know I think you know there's been a
some some loaded boxes and things like
that so it's made it tough for him but
you know as a total offense it's it's
huge and it's huge in our success and
and usana what you've seen it this year
when when he's had success in and he's
moved running the ball well this team
has had a lot of success so we're gonna
need it before and and you're a perfect
person to talk about this rivalry being
born and raised in Detroit Lakes
Minnesota being a Minnesota state er
yourself what does it mean to play the
Green Bay Packers in that great state of
Minnesota well number one Minnesota
states in the national championship this
week so go mad so we think in the finish
that one and then but yeah you know this
rivalry you know it's something that I
grew up going to took me to one game a
year and it was usually the factor
Vikings game so a lot of history which
is always
fun to be tailgating then seeing all the
Packer fans in the Vikings fans and you
know seeing the different things that
was going on there so it's pretty fun so
obviously always a great game whether
the teams are good or bad and just just
a really fun atmosphere I can't even
wait you know to get out there on Monday
night just to feel that atmosphere so is
there like a photograph of from back in
there I'm assuming in the Metrodome of
you booing the hell out of Favre is that
is that what we're talking about you
know there's you know there's an
interesting story to that probably
should never tell it but please I had
when I was very young you know it's like
four or five years old I actually was a
Brett Favre fan and had the D Brett
Favre jersey going to the Vikings
stadium at the Metrodome and and I got
harassed so much by Vikings fans that
turned me into like the same and that
was when I became a Christian
any monster on deck hopes up their fan
okay and really started going after the
like no I mean again that's why you're
the perfect person to talk about this
rivalry because you're here about
Packers Bears all the time right
especially last week they just play
their two hundred all-time meeting
playoffs included now you're saying you
four year old Adam Phelan wearing his
Brett Favre number four Packers gamer to
a game got harassed as a four-year-old
that's how this rivalry rolls and you
wound up a Vikings fan that's what
you're saying exactly I think I remember
there was a picture of you know the
Vikings fans you know I don't know they
were burning a Brett Favre or something
that wasn't really flipped because they
I don't want to get burned to the good
side but yeah I mean I I think I just
really loved the way that Brett Favre
played the game his no fear of mentality
just going out there and swinging it and
having fun doing it so that's probably
would what drew me to him but I'm glad I
switched over because you know watching
Chris Carter and Randy Moss
they're probably the biggest reason you
know Jake Reed things like that they're
probably the big reason why I'm where
I'm at today and crazy things can happen
Adam as you know Favre switched over to
eventually
oh yeah I remember trust me I I really
enjoyed those few years with heaven you
should have been a football champion now
team what one of those years but
unfortunately lost at the end there
well Adam good luck on you bringing a
championship there really appreciate the
time has always enjoy our chats and
let's chat down the road brother sounds
good I appreciate catch Adam Thielen of
the Minnesota Vikings at Thielen 19 on
Twitter for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app